well what was the vision of information
networking in 1989 is actually a reality
in today's world back in 93 we wanted to
create a testbed that could be used by
our wireless researchers we also hoped
we could build a wireless network
eventually for the entire Carnegie
Mellon campus one that would provide
high-speed Internet service to users of
mobile computers in 1993 I wrote a grant
proposal to the National Science
Foundation to create the wireless test
bed it was funded by NSF in early 94 and
then we were off and running it was
officially supposed to be used only by
the wireless researchers but we had lots
of inquiries from other people asking
essentially how do I get on the wireless
network and this was my first hint that
there really was a demand for this
anytime anywhere high-speed Internet
service that could be used by all
students faculty and staff anywhere on
the campus so we stepped up our
activities and within a few years we had
just that the campus-wide high-speed
wireless network to be used by any
member of the Carnegie Mellon community
wireless Andrew was a forerunner to what
we now call Wi-Fi